boys do you know why i brought you here
no
in 10 minutes a pool of lava will slowly
rise
every six seconds it will go up a block
and a block and just like in fortnite
the zone will slowly shrink with time
this is going to be one of the most epic
and hardest challenges we've ever done
but before the lava starts rising we
have 10 minutes to gather resources okay
all right only 10 minutes starting now
go gather whatever you want you can get
armor you could get wood
but in 10 minutes lava's gonna start
rising and it's not gonna stop until
everyone dies the winner gets to pick
which one of the three losers eats a
mustard
ketchup mayonnaise relish no stop and
horseradish combo we're gonna squirt it
all in a bowl
and the loser has to eat it oh hey guys
i found some iron
oh good for you oh creeper oh
man but why would you not gather
resources and do that later chris what
do you need resources for man
because we're going to pvp in the sky
don't you want iron armor oh are we
pee-pee
[Music]
i didn't know we were going to be pvping
up there why would we not
i don't know when did i say no pvps i
you didn't say pvps
i'm mining iron to be fair i got iron
for days i love how i just left a
furnace out in the open
cooking iron did anyone steal it you
played yourself who took my iron
chandler took my iron i'm nowhere near
you carl you took fire
i'm at i'm at why 27th it knows chris no
it's not me i'm just fighting the
enderman right now and i'm taking my
iron no i didn't show me your inventory
this is my iron over here show me your
inventory this is my iron do you guys
have no dignity how is everyone swearing
on their life they didn't take my
i did it i'm mine again
stealing is what you're doing
oh jimmy come on bud whoever wins
don't pick me to eat it because i'm
playing fair pick chris cause he stole
my eyes i didn't steal your iron
pause chris yes why are you dressed like
a knight because we got a sponsor
rise of kingdoms is a real-time strategy
game available on ios
and android hi there are 11 different
civilizations to choose from like china
france japan and rome the way the
movement in this game was designed
creates a ton of tactical possibilities
and the world and rise of kingdoms is
ginormous like your mom got it
you can explore and conquer mountains
plains forests rivers and even deserts
it's like traveling but you don't have
to pay for the travel if you like games
where you can explore and conquer this
is the app for you
imagine being able to change the entire
layout of your city with the tap of a
finger
it's annoying when buildings and games
like this all look the same which is why
in rise of kingdoms you literally can do
whatever you want download rise of
kingdoms today linked in the top
description build your city build an
army attack people form allies be a
pacifist do
literally whatever you want it's linked
in description and let's get back to
playing minecraft
five minutes remaining i'm not focusing
on torches i'm focusing on winning
he's not focusing on torches and
focusing on steel and iron from
jimmy no that's what carl does because
carl is a bloody thief
what a thief i'll tell you my strategy
love i'm going to get an iron a whole
lot of iron and then i'm going to win
this whole thing why do you need iron
why do you need iron why would i tell
you my strategy get away
my strategy is to get dirt because dirt
is amazing dirt does a lot of good for
us
dirt don't hurt and also i'm building to
the sky i need to find some spiders why
are you getting string for arrows
i don't want to tell you my strats here
i go going to get some spiders
really can't you guys think of your own
strats if i combine my strap with your
strat then it's a great strat we got
iron baby iron out the wazoo i don't
have fool by the way i'm one iron shy of
boots sorry you should have waited for
more of my iron to cook
i didn't get your iron you're so salty
you guys have a lot of material i do
let's just say we're going to be
building for quite a while boys i hope
you have a lot of resources
let's just say i play fortnite dude
where are the diamonds
i have found a ravine oh diamonds
dang the suspense is really building up
who invited him oh my gosh
where did these mobs come from everyone
time is up me that's fun
all right and here we go boys no more
klexi dexies
okay all right starting now we are
enemies
all right the lava will begin rising
good luck everybody
wait so can we start hitting each other
now why did everything yeah start
hitting each other everything got red
for a second oh my god the border
the border's shrinking too wait what
really i'm just giving you a taste all
right
troops truth how did you get a potion i
killed a witch
you know what potion it is healing
probably guys the lava is coming
let's truce until we get high in the air
okay so as i said the lava is now rising
so every six
seconds the lava goes up a block like
that all right guys
good luck don't burn or die i'm going up
oh my god
why are you building up near me why are
you building right near me
oh this sheep is going to be done for
why are you feeling it right there man
hey
true it's true it's true whoa no truce
remember when he tried to frame you
you took my iron no i didn't oh my gosh
this lava's rising so quick oh
guys oh my gosh dude this is actually
petrified oh my gosh why are you going
all the way out there jim jim
why do you care you get near me i don't
like you all up near me man all right
come on like really are we all just
gonna build straight up like this isn't
just straight up building simulator
everything's gone dude
all right well you want a battle i mean
like hey give me a chance to get up
there i'll fight hey isn't the borders
closing in holy cow
they're fishing so quick is this spiking
anyone else's anxiety
this gives me anxiety oh my gosh i can't
breathe right now don't let go of shift
i can't think about anything
who else's hands are just sweaty like
crazy the gamer's sweat is unreal right
now what you're doing
gym jam hey hey let's chill let's chill
on the same axis so chris
what brings you up here oh just chilling
just kill it who's that up there
oh
where's carl at wait yeah where is car
oh carl's over there hey carl
hi do you stay there all right i'm just
i'm getting a little nervous turning my
back to you you don't have a bow and
arrow you promise
i promise you you can look you can come
back i'm going over here because
i just i don't like looking at them and
you being right behind me last man
standing
wins and gets to pick whoever gets
punished all right so chandler's
building a fortress up there and i don't
like how it's eerily getting above me oh
chris you're building all right we're
building
all right we're doing this we got a
truce why do you guys have a truce we
don't we just have a mutual a mutual
understanding for five seconds yeah
and by the way if you see me pull my
sword out it's just so boring what did
jimmy just do what did jimmy just do
he shot me with an error oh it doesn't
sound like truce talk to me
something to think about if you win
chris boyk
oh oh i'm almost out of arrows all right
chris chris let's be reasonable let's be
reasonable chris
oh shoot my hands are sweating come on
man you come on keep wasting your arrows
on me i got a shield
okay so is the strat to get to world
height and build a base are you guys
teaming
no i'm just talking out loud carl
appears to be wasting a lot of cobble i
don't know if that's the most efficient
method chris kill him i'll kill carl
it's not gonna do anything
i only know chris is that health is
looking mighty low
oh oh come on bro i'm drinking a potion
all right wait are you what are you two
doing over there guys i just eliminated
someone the least you guys can do is
eliminate one of you why do why do i
have to do all the dirty work build up
build up
in case you see someone flying it's
chris i'm at the height limit the lava
is slowly rising we've hit height limit
carl all i'm saying is you could build
over top of chandler and you could just
seal them off hey chris
hey bud are you mad i killed you don't
hit me
stop you can't do this you can't you're
dead you're dead
accept it you lost don't make me ban you
i will ban you
i just gave him one arrow i if i see any
more shenanigans i'm banning
why is it the whole world against me
here i'll give you an error what did i
do
i'll give you an error give me give me
five okay okay what
i don't even have a bow i'm kidding give
me whatever you gave carl to make it
fair you ruined my whole strat now that
i can't build over
oh wait how did i ruin your stretch can
you guys stop being babies and like
fight
i already eliminated someone comment
section i'm at a disadvantage
i took out chris and these two weenie
huts over here
and the junior lives are trying to
double team me take out a person
and then they team me what is this what
what did i do if taylor falls off his
base he's pretty good
as long as he times it just right oh now
carl's doing it
i've had a bunch of buckets ready i've
had buckets way to give away the strats
chris no chandler you're on that side of
him i'm on this side how about we just
double bob
start shrinking the zone shrink the zone
how about we double team the double team
double team the double teamer when did i
double team uh remember
carl stole your iron jimmy so oh oh
oh oh oh boy
bike
chandler they double team how can they
double team you man that's not even
right
if either of us wins which we will
neither of us
vote for the other one yeah if i win i
won't make you eat food say you will you
not make me
i won't make you eat food okay now it's
time i gotta kill you
nope
what just happened what just happened
what just happened and i have a number
between one and two whoever guesses it
first
all right carl carl i want you to hold
it for him while he eats it because
you're the reason he's doing this this
is
literally only your fault i kind of feel
bad for killing you chris
you should i do but i stole your iron
you did you
[Applause]
that's not enough i want more he stole
my iron
more ride
all right that's for stealing my